how you guys doing great how are you
doing good very happy to be here in
outer space
yeah very strange isn't it very second
it's almost like a trippy haunted house
and yes it's exactly like time to just
pop out many of yeah I would love that
that would be me um so the lego movie
when did you first learn that you were
taking over this thing and Kenta tell me
about that moment when they were like
okay here's here's this massive thing
that you are now in charge of well Chris
and Phil visited me for the last time I
was directing you tell me out and they
mentioned that they wanted make a sequel
and I said you should not make a sequel
to the Lego film cuz that to me that's
the perfect film I love the first film
and I just thought it was so charming
with Chris Pratt is Emmett you can't do
it again and then they pitched this
story to me and I was like that is a
great idea that is such a great sequel
and I have to be a part of it and
especially with just introducing the
character the little sister is such a
great idea yeah I just came off of
working on Lego Batman so when I heard
that you know Mike was working on Lego -
and I heard that was all gonna be from
the sisters point of view I was like
sign me up I'm wondering when when you
took the stewardship of this thing how
you wanted to inject your own little
twist on your own personal how you want
to inject your personal brand on - I
mean I'm a little sister so like oh this
is amazing I get to kind of like create
a world that I would have created you
know when I was a kid so I'm Trisha is
the her artwork is very mixed media with
like paper and glitter and - a crafty
and that's exactly what this that's what
we did with the little girls universe
and singing and dancing everything I've
ever worked on what was the sort of
toughest nut to crack either visually or
story-wise what was the thing that we
were like me I don't know how we're
gonna get the stuff but it did come out
father recently for me we have a
flashback with some time-travel going on
within that flashback it was a very
difficult story to tell yeah it was I
agree the story that this story is so
ambitious and it was a tricky story to
tell but I mean I think you know it paid
off in droves
there's also reveals of people that you
thought were villains that are actually
good guys and good guys that become
villains and that was a very complicated
probably the most difficult story I've
ever worked at yes amazing well they
came off it worked great good but some
of them oh it's one of the most fun
thing about these Lego movies is all the
cameos from other IP and stuff like that
is there anything that you're
particularly happy made a taint or
something you're particularly proud
getting yes Larry Poppins I'm so happy
that Larry Poppins made which really
isn't a character that exists now he
does it's a cameo from someone that does
not exist right and in terms of Easter
eggs things that are that things that
are sort of hitted in the background or
anything is there anything like that
for you guys personally is anything that
you're very happy made it that you might
you think people might not know it is
some other first review I well I know my
effects guy gave me a little robed
minifig that's holding a staff and he
gave it to me on the last day and he was
like I'm giving you this and I was like
who's this guy and he's like he's called
the wanderer and the effects team has
put him in the back of a lot of Where's
Waldo of the of the crowd so I was like
oh my gosh now I get a treat of a mood
part of the movie where I don't because
I know what's in every child except for
this wonderer guy so now I got it's
amazing now I got to go find the lawn
[Music]